qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à
ceux qui justement quand une
contradiction entre vos positions
personnelles et le fait d'avoir
plusieurs véhicules et contradictions
j'en ai eu j'en aurai j'en ai encore je
pourrais les assumer sauf quand elles ne
sont pas exacts qu'il ya six véhicules
dans mon patrimoine c'est la stricte
vérité
mais bon dans la maison dans ma famille
nous sommes c'est le patrimoine de la
famille donc nous sommes déjà trois
membres de la famille et utiliser ces
véhicules par ailleurs il se trouve que
j'ai deux lieux de vie donc il ya les
véhicules qui servent un gardien dans
une maison que j'ai dans la montagne en
corse et qu'une sauf qu'à son usage
moi ce qui compte vous m'auriez posé
cette question il ya 10 ou 15 ans je
suis pas sûr que j'aurais eu la même
réponse 90% de mes déplacements se font
en véhicule électrique et pas depuis que
je suis ministre
pardon mais un scooter électrique à
paris ça fait plus de dix ans peut-être
quinze ans que j'ai un scooter
électrique le véhicule électrique c'est
mon deuxième véhicule écrit que c'est
pas acheter simplement pour faire bien
simplement la seule chose c'est que pour
les déplacements familiaux au jour
d'aujourd'hui quand on veut vraiment
partir en vacances en famille j'ai pas
de véhicule électrique parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de tenue le jour où je
pourrais avoir un véhicule électrique
nous permettra d'avoir un seul véhicule
à la place de deux voilà donc si vous
divisez par le membre de la famille et
puis parler de lieu de vie égard n'ya
pour finir tout ça et tu te fais la
seule chose c'est que les gens
comprennent pas pourquoi pas en danger
une deux chevaux parce que j'ai gardé
une affection pour cette de choses j'ai
pas envie de la vente je n'ai plus de 25
ans elle est dans un garage et une fois
par an elle sort chez ma petite sortie
en deux choses et je laisse hume ou les
petits simplement à ceux qui jugent si
vous faites 90% de déplacement
électrique alors venez me juger